Speaker 1: In another vaccine related occurrence,
you know, it's it is a strange thing to me
that there are certain people who just love
to be owned.
And Peter, see The Dingess over at Fox News,
who is now their White House correspondent,
which used to be a lofty position, something
you would strive for because it meant you
were at the top of your game instead.
Nepotism junior over there at Fox News.
He's the he's the correspondent.
Well, yesterday at the briefing, it was Sunday,
Sunday, Sunday.
It's like a monster truck rally with Peter
Doocy just getting smashed by Jen Psaki.
This moment transpired.
And buckle up because it is blue.
Speaker 3: President tries to reach unvaccinated
Americans.
Has there been any thought given, looking
back to the possibility that he may have created
some vaccine hesitancy when last year around
this time the previous administration was
rushing to get a vaccine authorized and the
vice president said, I trust vaccines, I trust
scientists, but I don't trust Donald Trump
at this moment.
The American people can't either.
Speaker 4: Well, I think it's safe to say
he still doesn't trust Donald Trump, so that
hasn't changed.
But he does trust scientists.
He does trust data experts, and he does trust
the people leading the CDC, the FDA, which
is the gold standard of approval for vaccines.
I'd also note, because this question often
comes up, that the president has repeatedly
given credit to scientists and experts from
the prior administration, even as recently
as just a few weeks ago, for their role in
moving the vaccine forward.
Speaker 3: Yes, but at the time when Donald
Trump is out there saying we're going to have
a vaccine in the next couple of weeks, next
couple of months, and Joe Biden is out on
the campaign trail saying don't trust Donald
Trump.
Did that create any kind of vaccine hesitancy?
Speaker 4: Not that we've seen in the data.
I would note that at the time, just for context,
the former president was also suggesting people
inject versions of poison into their veins
to cure covid.
So I think that's a relevant plan.
Speaker 3: Joe Biden, then vice president,
was saying we got to wait until something
is fully authorized and it's still not.
Speaker 4: Well, the FDA works on the timeline
of science.
At the same time, we've also seen tens of
millions of people's lives saved who have
gotten the vaccine.
That data is clear across the country.
Speaker 1: Go ahead.
So Peter Doocy is accusing Joe Biden of creating
vaccine hesitancy in the United States.
Oh, come on, man.
This is an unbelievable thing.
And by the way, a great off the cuff moment
for Jen Psaki to mention.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You're not going to do this.
Your guy, your guy that you're fighting to
defend right now is the guy who remember and
I'm going to play the clip because it is one
of those moments that we should never forget
it.
It's another one of those moments that we
should cherish that we're not living in that
era anymore.
The era of Donald Trump when he did absolutely,
unequivocally suggest that people.
That it could be a workable solution to fight
the virus if we were to inject disinfectant
into our bodies.
Speaker 5: Supposing we hit the body with
a tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or just
very powerful light.
And I think you said that has a magic, but
you're going to test it.
And then I said, supposing you brought the
light inside the body, you can which you can
do either through the skin or in some other
way.
And I think you said you're going to test
that, too.
Sounds interesting, right?
And then I see the disinfectant, which knocks
it out in a minute.
One minute.
And is there a way we can do something like
that by injection inside or or almost a cleaning?
Because you see it gets in the lungs and it
does a tremendous number.
So it'll be interesting to check that so that
you're going to have to use medical doctors.
But it sounds it sounds interesting to me.
Speaker 1: So just remember that.
Don't let sidetracking questions from idiots
like Peter Doocy distract you from the fact
that, one, we have a competent, empathetic,
decent man as president of the United States,
not now, not not a Dingess who dangerously
suggests that disinfectant could cure the
virus inside the body.
I mean, there is something to rejoice about,
is
there not?